cette saison à montigny gabriel par
l'horaire porte le maillot machine à
buts dernière batterie de lucarnes face
à plouvorn l'arrière gauche a marqué le
tiers des buts de son équipe avec 10
réalisations
une victoire qui fait du bien après
trois défaites consécutives
sur un poste d'arrière c'est rock sur la
pac placé sur le jeu qu'on met en place
en attaque placée on a pas mal de combi
qui finit sur les arrières donc ça me
donne plus de chance sur attaque
classique une ailière qu'habite une
chose importante du dispositif de
l'équipe c'est une buteuse alliance une
deuxième fille qui doutent pas du tout
après on a eu un début de saison marqué
beaucoup de buts mais elle avait son
petit péché mignon de perdre beaucoup de
ballons et lala samedi à l'ami et
l'efficacité et défensivement et
offensivement ce qu'a fait comme 10 sur
11 aux tirs ce qui est quand même pas
rien
issu d'une famille de handballeur à 14
ans gabriel et poussé sur les parcs et
par sa mère formé au pôle espoirs de
strasbourg pendant trois saisons gaby
fait ses grands débuts en nationale une
arnheim à l'âge de 17 ans avant de
passer par strasbourg c'est alors que
commence l'histoire d'amour avec
montigny malgré une séparation de deux
ans l'alsacienne pause durablement ses
valises à coubertin en 2009 cette saison
sept responsables administratifs de 28
ans s'est vu confier le brassard de
capitaine un rôle qu'elle découvre match
après match je n'aime pas quand les
filles sont fond du trou et quasi reste
trois donc j'essaie quand même de faire
en sorte qu au moins les filles qui sont
à côté de moi puisque c'est cela qui je
peux parler sur le terrain aille de
l'avant relève la tête quand quand il le
faut ou continue d'être performante
quand elle croit pas que le fonds allait
bien
et elle nous donne toutes les
informations
ou passent par elle pour quoi que ce
soit et c'est une très bonne qualité
moyenne par rapport à sa stature en
polymère dans l'équipe le voilà son jeu
il me semblait logique soit la capitaine
foyer sincèrement pas qu'ils mettent
d'autres comme capitaine stade elle est
respectée par le groupe
après pour pouvoir te brassard il faut
quelqu'un qui soit bien respectée par
groupe et qui payent qui est une une
voix qui porte c'est un peu ce cas là
pas pour l'instant parce qu'elle a un
peu de mal à s'imposer atout offensif
numéro un de la smb handball avec 36
buts en cinq journées soit plus de sept
buts par match en moyenne
gabriel parloir montre le chemin ses
coéquipières pour atteindre l'objectif
de fin de saison le maintien en
nationale 2